[Musique]
vous me faites le coup depuis hier vous
êtes vraiment un d'incapables
allez faites quelque chose ou bar vous
allez foot est comme food et j'ai même
pas entendu et un sifflet je me suis dit
les gens vont user et tooway un mois je
me suis mal comporté là je me suis mal
comporté bon on est d'accord
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
truc qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'astronomie
je vais vous parler du pluriel de
politesse vous en général les gens
voient le vouvoiement comme une marque
de politesse de respect mais je crois
que j'ai été capable de vous donner un
contre exemple juste à l'instant
et si on veut aller encore plus loin
dans contre exemple si le mouvement est
une forme de respect pourquoi vous
tutoyez vos proches vos amis un peu
bizarre non si la science est basée sur
la réputation c'est pas si d'ailleurs
c'est le cas dans le milieu scientifique
il suffit d'une réfutation pour mettre à
mal une théorie penser que tel modèle
est vrai vous trouvez un contre exemple
c'est foutu si on applique la méthode
scientifique là tout de suite je crois
qu'on peut se dire que j'ai démontré que
le vouvoiement n'est absolument pas une
forme de respect vu comme j'ai malmené
killian pour moi le vouvoiement c'est
pas du tout une marque de respect c'est
une marque de distance voire même de
soumission on va faire un petit peu
d'histoire parce que cela dit tout à
l'heure j'étais enseignant d'abord j'ai
fait une formation de prof d'histoire et
donc on va faire un petit peu d'histoire
on va parler des origines du vouvoiement
et les origines du vouvoiement enfin les
plus lointaines que j'ai trouvé on les
trouve dans le latin sous le règne de
dioclétien aux alentours de 285 300 et à
ce moment là
le pouvoir impérial est divisé entre
quatre individus mais les romains aime
bien les trucs un peu chelou
si vous aussi vous vous adressez à l'un
des quatre représentants du pouvoir vous
vous adressez forcément aux trois autres
même s'ils sont pas dans la même pièce
donc vous vous voyez ce représentant du
pouvoir
ça c'est les plus anciennes traces du
vouvoiement qu'on a on va faire un petit
bond dans le temps d'environ 500 va
aller jusqu'au carolingien et les
carolingiens les rois carolingiens amène
une nouvelle mode c'est de vous voyez
les nobles parce que pourquoi pas encore
un petit peu plus tard au courant du
moyen âge en voit apparaître le pluriel
de majesté le roi qui parle de lui-même
en disant nous et qui demande aux gens
qui s'adressent à lui de le vouvoyer
maintenant je vais faire une petite
digression vous allez voir j'aime
beaucoup les digressions les petites
histoires
après avoir été enseignant j'étais
photographe de mariage aussi est ce que
vous savez pourquoi
les robes de mariées sont blanches on
nous dit souvent que c'est la virginité
la pureté mon oeil est vous n'allez pas
me croire qu'elles n'ont pas vu le loup
avant le mariage
non en fait ça c'est une construction a
posteriori ça n'a absolument rien à voir
au moyen âge quand les jeunes fils
mariés elles prenaient leurs plus belles
robes et surtout la plus colorée gens
n'achetaient pas une spécialement pour
l'occasion et le prenez le robe très
colorée
celle qui a apporté la mode de la robe
blanche c'est la reine victoria qui a
son mariage était tout de blanc vêtus et
si je vous raconte ça qu'il a absolument
rien à voir ou presque c'est parce que
ce sont souvent les puissants enfin
c'était en tout cas les puissants qui
crée les modes et d'ailleurs quand je
dis c'était aujourd'hui sont encore
souvent les stars qui créent les modes
quand un puissant quand un roi
quand un empereur faisait quelque chose
demain les roturiers les petites gens
tout ça pour limiter faisait pareil et
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est retrouvé avec
le vouvoiement d'abord chez les nobles
et noble les rois et c est finalement
chez les petites gens
maintenant on va encore faire un petit
bond dans le temps on va parler de la
révolution française plus
particulièrement de l'em2 du calendrier
de la révolution française
en l'an 2 on a pris une décision un peu
bizarre c'est d'abolir le vouvoiement
abolir une forme de politesse c'est
bizarre à moins qu'on ait aboli une
forme de soumission et là dans le cadre
de la révolution française bas ça
devient tout de suite beaucoup plus
logique
aujourd'hui le vouvoiement existe bien
entendu toujours ou comme les inégalités
comme quoi la révolution a eu un impact
est limité mais on n'est pas tous égaux
devant le vouvoiement par exemple pour
ce tome que j'ai fait quelques petites
recherches et j'ai vite constaté qu'au
québec par exemple on tutoie beaucoup
plus facilement qu'en france et en
france on tutoie beaucoup plus
facilement qu'en belgique
j'ai pas fais des recherches complètes
sur toute la france la francophonie mais
bon on peut parler encore de quelques
autres exemples par exemple si vous
allez en espagne vous serez peut-être
surpris de constater que les publicités
vous tutoient beaucoup plus facilement
qu'en france une publicité qui vous
tutoient en france c'est pas courant
ben en espagne beaucoup plus et puis
après il ya évidemment l'exemple aussi
anglophones en anglais il ya que yu il
existait un tue en anglais sarah ça ou
je ne sais pas comment ça se prononce
parce que je n'ai jamais vu qu'à l'écrit
et pour cause il est totalement tombée
en désuétude ça n'existe plus ça s'écrit
thq vous l'avez peut-être vu passer
quelque part et c'est l'ancien tu
anglais qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui il
n'ya plus que l'oeil ou universel c'est
une forme de vouvoiement mais
aujourd'hui ça n'a plus vraiment ce sens
là et le vouvoiement anglais est un
petit peu moins de forme de soumission
quand même vu que tout le monde est logé
à la même enseigne c'est à dire que si
vous vous adressez à la reine
d'angleterre ou vous adresser à votre
frangine bas vous avez vous parlé de la
même manière en français on a cette
différence entre le tutoiement qui est
vu comme une forme de familiarité le
vouvoiement qui est vu comme une forme
de respect j'espère vous avoir montré
que ce n'était pas le cas mais il ya un
cas qui moi personnellement me révulse
presque c'est le vouvoiement asymétrique
s'appelle pas spécialement comme ça
c'est moi qui vous donne le nom là tout
de suite mais pour vous donner un
exemple c'est par exemple dans une
entreprise
vous avez le patron qui va tutoyer ses
employés et les employés qui eux on vous
voyait le patron moi ça me dérange un
petit peu parce que si vous vraiment
être une marque de respect ça veut dire
qu'il ya que le patron qui mérite le
respect et s'il veut vraiment être une
forme de soumission pas beaucoup mieux
en fait les conférences ted ça sert à
partager des idées slogan c'est ça moi
l'idée que je vous ramène aujourd'hui
c'est que le vouvoiement c'est dépassé
c'est une idée purement personnelle
c'est pas une vérité absolue mais c'est
l'idée que je vous apporte aujourd'hui
je pense que le vouvoiement est
complètement dépassé je pense que le
tutoiement n'est pas plus une marque de
familiarité que le vouvoiement est une
marque de respect je pense que le
tutoiement est une marque de proximité
et d'égalité
là où le vouvoiement est une marque de
distance et de soumission et pour
prendre mon exemple personnel je tutoie
tout le monde que je rencontre un
astronaute un élu un mec dans la rue à
qui je demande mon chemin je vais le
tutoyer la parfois y en a qui veulent
pas il ya des gens qui ne supportent pas
qu'on es tu toi
et même quand je leur ai fait cette
explication que veulent toujours pas
alors puisqu'on parle de respectueux
depuis tout à l'heure je vais être un
petit peu irrespectueux envers ces gens
si jamais il y en a là dans la salle qui
ne supporte pas qu on les tutoie
je vais vous voyez mais je manquais un
peu de respect vous êtes des vieux cons
rétrograde voilà alors je vais vous le
dire quand même un petit peu autrement
on va essayer à ces gens là qu'est ce
qui vous donne la légine la légitimité
de refuser à d'autres de se mettre sur
un pied d'égalité avec vous parce que
pour moi quand vous forcer quelqu'un
vous vous voyez vous forcez cette
distance vous forcez cette soumission
si le tutoiement est un manque de
respect ça je sais pas ce que c'est
le sujet des talks d'aujourd'hui c'est
la plasticité
quand on m'a invité je suis vivant je
parle d'astronomie sur youtube
l'asti cité dans l'astronomie le
plastique dans l'astronomie
ouf j'ai pas trop trouvé comment faire
le lien alors j'ai décidé de de parler
de cette petite histoire personnelle on
va dire et si donc on parle de
plasticité c'est parce que quelque part
je comprends aussi les gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se défaire du
vouvoiement pourquoi parce que c'est
dans les moeurs et on a du mal à changer
nos habitudes je ne comprends
parfaitement
c'est normal et pour illustrer sa je
vais encore vous raconter une petite
histoire parce que je crois que vous
avez compris que j'aime bien les petites
histoires
maintenant je vais vous parler de ma
maman maman qui est assez à cheval sur
le respect d'ailleurs je pense qu'elle
regrette un petit peu ce que je suis
devenu je plaisante
presque non mais maman rencontrée il ya
quelques années une dame est tout
naturellement elle ce sont vous voyez
mais le hasard a fait que ces deux
personnes sont devenues très bonne amie
et maintenant elle se fréquentent tout
le temps ils passent leur week-end
ensemble etc
elles ont continué à se vouvoyer depuis
tout ce temps là parce que pourquoi
changer et là où c'est un peu bizarre
c'est que quand elles sont en société
avec d'autres amis en sont pleins de
gens elle tutoie tout le monde tout le
monde les tutoie sauf l2 qui se
vouvoient bon alors je leur ai fait la
remarque un jeu lundi mais pourquoi
alors maman comme tout le monde y met
c'est une marque de respect voyons ah
bon
et toutes ces autres copines que tu toi
alors et là du coup elle se sont
regardés avons rigolé lundi oui c'est
vrai qu'en fait bon donc elles ont
essayé de se tutoyer et évidemment on se
vouvoie toujours pourquoi pas parce
qu'elles en ont l'habitude depuis des
années elles ce sont vous voyez c'est
difficile de changer
je ne conçois parfaitement par contre
j'ai quand même envie de dire encore une
chose à tous les gens qui ont du mal à
changer leurs habitudes
j'en fait parti aussi mais vous savez
cette génération qui va vous dire oui
mais de mon temps on vous voyez ces
parents petits galopins joie j'ai envie
de leur dire oui mais de ton temps il y
avait aussi des télé en noir et blanc et
des téléphones à cadran
aujourd'hui tu es aussi passer à la télé
couleur et au téléphone portable donc ça
aussi normalement on devrait pouvoir
envisager de le changer
donc pour apporter une petite nuance à
ce que j'ai dit je tutoie tout le monde
ou presque je tutoie les gens que quand
je suis dans une situation où
éventuellement je pourrais leur
expliquer ce que je viens de vous
expliquer là sans forcément faire autant
de circonvolutions autour mais si je
peux expliquer ça aux gens je vais le
tutoyer
par exemple je viens d'un petit patelin
la frontière de l'alsace j'espère que ça
s'entend et quand je vais chez mon
boucher la petite la petite boucherie au
fin fond de la campagne je tutoie mon
boucher
je vais arrêter avec l'accent ça va deux
minutes pourquoi parce que je le vois
régulièrement on peut de temps en temps
et changer on a le temps donc je peux
créer ce lien de proximité
mais si je vais dans un supermarché avec
l'employé qui à la boucherie et qui a
l'obligation de vous voyez les clients
si je le tutoie je vais le mettre dans
une situation d'inconfort dont je
parlais tout à l'heure c'est ce
vouvoiement asymétrique au moins je vais
le tutoyer je vais me mettre à mon aise
et lui il pourra pas et je vais le
placer comme ça ont subordonné et ça
c'est pas cool et il ya trois mecs qui
attendent derrière moi pour se faire
servir j'ai pas le temps de lui
expliquer qu'il a droit de me tutoyer
que pourquoi le tutoiement etc
et en plus si lui se met à tutoyer un
client c'est pas exclu qu'il gérants
qu'ils voient derrière qui lui met un
une claque derrière les oreilles
donc dans ce cas là je vais pas chercher
les complications je vais vous voyez de
même je suis dans la rue je veux
demander mon chemin à quelqu'un si c'est
un homme je vais le tutoyer
mais si c'est une femme j'ai quand même
conscience que la rue remplie de gros
lourd qui cherche la moindre excuse
bidon pour faire de la drague bien
merdique et donc si j'ai pas envie de
mettre une femme mal à l'aise en lui
faisant croire que moi aussi je suis un
énième mec en train de la draguer et bat
pour garder justement cette distance je
vais là vous voyez
en conclusion je vous suggère d'essayer
en sortant de cette salle essayez de
tutoyer les gens je dire en plus ça
devrait pas être trop dur parce que à
part les 2 3 qui peut-être dorment au
fond de la salle non ça va normalement
vous avez tous compris ce que je voulais
dire vous êtes peut-être pas d'accord
mais si vous voyez quelqu'un vous
tutoyer la tout à l'heure dans le
couloir normalement vous comprendrez
pourquoi il le fait donc essayé essayé
de tutoyer les gens autour de vous et
vous verrez que ça change
votre rapport aux gens vous verrez que
inconsciemment
quand on dit vous à quelqu'un on place
une distance mais tout aussi
inconsciemment quand on dit tu on se
présente en ami et moi quand je
rencontre quelqu'un
potentiellement c'est un futur ami donc
je préfère le tutoyer merci monsieur
dame c'était arnaud thierry un petit con
qui manque de respect aux vieux merci et
à la revoyure
[Applaudissements]